cette requête par humain il s'agit que
l'allemagne reste stable et peu importe
qui gouverne l'allemagne va dans notre
sens treglia
armin laschet tu ne vient pas de
n'importe où il vient d'aix-la-chapelle
il a appris la politique depuis très
longtemps il dirige ce land de rhénanie
du nord-wesphalie avec réussite et ce
land à de multiples passes et
un soutien inconditionnel apporté par la
chancelière à son potentiel successeur
armin l'achète dans un scrutin qui
s'annonce plutôt serré en retard dans
les sondages le candidat de la cd ou cs
ou est pour le moment donné perdant face
au spd d'olaf choles selon les dernières
estimations
les sociaux démocrates sont en tête avec
25% des intentions de vote les chrétiens
démocrates remporteraient quant à eux
entre 21 et 23% des suffrages
entre le spd l'a cédée ou cs ou
plusieurs retournements de situation ont
eu lieu depuis le début de la campagne
de leur côté les électeurs allemands ont
des attentes bien précises concernant ce
scrutin
le climat c'est important mais il ne
faut pas y aller au bulldozer c'est ce
qui se passe actuellement personne ne se
parle mais il ne faut pas oublier les
thèmes importants l'économie les
entreprises les indépendants et les
artisans à me faire connaître à gaza tu
as porté nos maîtres à gaza
j'espère qu'on prendra en compte le vote
de la jeunesse on ne représente qu'une
petite partie des électeurs et 7 aux
générations d'avant de décider avec nous
[Musique]
alors que le candidat du spd olaf
schulze a déclaré vouloir un changement
et un renouveau pour l'allemagne les
conservateurs pourrait connaître leur
pire score électoral
depuis l'après guerre le centre droit
qui a fourni cinq des huit chancelier a
toujours dépassé les 30% lors des
scrutins nationaux